welcome everyone to new coffee break
with me here Heinrich on from learning
the channel where I want to help you
become successful in the first years of
your career and one from you someone
from the audience sent me a slide deck
of one of the largest companies in the
world of Amazon and it is a slide deck
that was presented in one of their
quarterly conference calls where they
present the latest Financial figures
often to a set of analysts and other
important stakeholders to give them an
update of how the company is going the
reason I want to discuss this with you
today is because frankly this is one of
the worst slide sets of this importance
that I have ever seen created by any of
these large companies I think this is
quite remarkable so I want to discuss
with you first what makes these slides
so bad and second I want to discuss what
you could do to improve them if at any
point in your career you would be in the
position to create slides like this as
well so let's start by having a first
look at the slides before we go into the
details so you the other cover slide of
this already looks quite busy to say the
least the next one seems to be some type
of legal slide of course Very text heavy
but okay for legal style I guess that's
fine and then these are the typical
slides that you see here in the deck and
I hope that you agree without even going
into the details here just the first
look and feel is just very bad it looks
like an absolute amateur I would have
created this every intern who just spent
a couple of months in Professional
Services I would claim would be able to
create Superior slides compared to this
and now before we look into the slides
on detail let me first stress one point
which might actually be the most
important point so what do you want to
accomplish in such a financial earnings
call well there are all these analysts
all these investors to whom you talk to
and you share with them the financial
numbers and this is exactly what's
happened here so just slide after slide
they're just sharing some random numbers
what would an investor likely think if
the investor sees a slide like this so
the free cash flowly available cash flow
seems to go significantly down on over
the last year or so but there's no
statement no explanation no rationale
about this at all the only comment is
that there's a long-term goal to
optimize free cash flow what does this
mean how is this giving any confidence
to investors at all if there's anyone at
this company working who has some type
of plan what needs to be done what was
even driving this decline in full cash
flow for instance so all of these
obvious questions are not answered at
all this is more or less just a data
dump it lacks any narrative it lacks any
storyline if you want to learn more
about what you can do to actually
improve this for your slides I created
lots of videos on this in the past
probably the entry point for this
specific topic would be the videos on
action titles that I created I will link
it somewhere of our field for your
reference but now let's go a bit more
into the details really the composition
of these slides and I just start you
with the very first slide and of course
many of the things that I discuss here
on this slide are relevant to all the
other slides as well and that just first
talk about the aspect ratio of this so
this is a slide with an aspect ratio of
four to three and this is just so
incredibly outdated even when I started
in Consulting in McKinsey in 2013 I
believe it was almost no one was using
this four to three format anymore today
almost every slide that you create are
done in a 16 to 9 aspect ratio where it
gives you the benefit that you have far
more space on the slide and it also
gives you the benefit that now there
aren't black bars to the left and to the
right so this alone just completely
outdated really so surprising they're
doing it then second let's look at this
one of the things that just makes the
slide look busy not really clean and
nice it's just all the different font
sizes that have been utilized here so
notice here how this long term goal this
is bigger than here the Q3 axes are
smaller but then the axis on the y-axis
are bigger again then here the numbers
are the same as on the y-axis also some
other things for instance these two dash
here just look very unprofessional why
would you do that what exactly is the
meaning of this now let's look also at
the chart itself so first of all there's
one principle that I want you to have in
mind and this is the principle of the
data to Ink ratio so just very basic
principle is that you always want to
show as much data as possible with as
little ink as possible ink referring to
any lines that you are drawing on the
page just a common thing that is just
not necessary at all especially if you
have bar charts like this just to have
this additional y-axis why do you even
need this y-axis just take it out
because then of course you have the
numbers on top of the bars this is at
least what I would recommend you to do
to have numbers on top of the bars
because for whatever reason these ladies
and gentlemen at Amazon decided that
they just include a number on the very
first bar and the very last bar why is
this the case so what if not someone
would want to know what here in Q2 2021
the trailing 12 months average was is
the person supposed to know take out a
ruler and someone try to understand
based on the axis what number here for
Q2 is the Right One In addition to this
idea of data to Ink ratio why is there
this weird light blue background here in
this chart what value is this adding
what is this saying this just wastes ink
especially if you print out such a page
on a black and white printer depending
on the contrast setting of the printer
you might not be even able to just
separate the bar from the background
anymore because the background is
colored as well so just absolutely no
need for doing that don't just randomly
use background colors like this if it's
not needed let's also just look at
another inconsistency of this page so
let's look at negative numbers let's
first look here at the axis so we see
that this axis goes down to minus 40 000
actually here with this Legend minus 40
million US dollar I guess but here now
this is denoted as a million whereas
here the negative number is denoted with
these two brackets which is another way
of denoting a negative number which is a
fine way you can do that though I would
say not the most intuitive I think not
everyone understands this but if you do
then at least do it consistently
throughout the chart why would you use
the one indentation on the one inside
and then the other annotation at the
other hand side just another smaller
thing that I also talked about in some
videos is the use of this dollar sign
that's always a bit of a problem maybe
you could argue the way for Amazon it's
clear that this is your s dollar but
let's at least add knowledge that
there's so many dollars on the world
there are Canadian dollars Australian
dollars Singapore dollar Taiwanese
dollar and so on and so forth and at
least as far as I know all of them use
this dollar sign so don't use this
dollar sign to just denote the currency
but rather use this three letter acronym
right so USD for US dollar for instance
if you would want to talk about dollars
next let's talk about alignment so the
basic idea is when you arrange elements
on such a page that there should be as
few just logical levels logical areas on
the plane of the slide as possible and
just to start here at the left usually
you think about design spaces where the
slide starts at a given point to the
left and ends at a given point to the
right and this is maybe a minor comment
but for sure if you would work at a firm
like McKinsey BCG Bane I mean you will
get feedback on things like that right
so this bar here the long term goals
this border around it this starts to the
left but actually the axis of the chart
starts further to the right of this
right so it's not really a line to the
left border of the page and there's no
apparent hierarchical argument
hierarchical reason why that would be
the case next let's look here at the
legend on top the mm on top so this is
neither Center to the 80 000 unit that
is shown here nor is it left aligned to
this unit so just somewhere randomly
placed here on the chart let's also look
here to the right hand side of this
chart where you see that also here the
chart doesn't analyze the line to the
right border of this border around the
long term go attacks box let's look here
at the footnote that also just seems to
replace the completely randomly it is
neither aligned to the Border here of
the long-term goals box it is also not
aligned to hear the dollar sign so it
starts further to the right than this
dollar sign so just looks completely
random and then last but not least let's
also talk about this two keys box here
that says down 171 percent year on year
I guess this means which is also just
randomly pasty right so it's not nicely
centered you would expect this to be
centered it's also brief you talk about
the messaging of the page we also
briefly touched upon it in the beginning
of the video so first of all I would
always recommend you think this is what
the professional standard is to use the
so-called action titles on slides so not
just writing free cash flow but using an
action title but then even if we read
this takeaway boxes you could call it
here at the bottom it has a long-term
goal optimize free cash flows again what
does this mean how do you know so first
of all what is the long-term goal second
of all how do they optimize free cash
flow if I look at this they're not
optimizing free cash flow at all right
free cash flow seems to be going down
like crazy so if they have a goal in the
future what is the goal and what are the
tangible measures that they want to put
forward How can any analyst trust that
they will succeed to do that based on
the slide I think that's a very big
problem next slide like this where we
talk about net sales again just notice
how this is just a data dump just some
numbers again the most important numbers
are you missing here because it's not
really appearing on the bars but let's
notice that this turquies bubble here on
top so here it says up seven percent
year on year but then also up nine
percent FX adjusted so if x is the
foreign exchange rate but now if I look
at the numbers are these not the
adjusted numbers so we have X adjusted
numbers or are these the non-fx adjusted
numbers and now there's even a footnote
now I'm reading the footnote but I'm not
really getting this from the footnote
now of course I cannot start doing the
map start calculating whether 116 over
108 rather corresponds to 7 or to nine
percent the summer I get to it but of
course this is just very unprofessional
the numbers not labeled correctly just
leave so many questions when looking at
this now let's look at a slide like this
so I think of course many things already
commented on our parent here as well of
course here the use of pie charts in the
right is also problematic so also
created a video about data visualization
in the past that will also link it above
here where I talk about why the use of
pie charts is in most cases
unprofessional I think you're seeing
many of the problems here as well but
now ask yourself also how is this pie
chart related here to the chart on the
left how exactly does this go together
and now I trust if you maybe now pause
the video and think about it after some
time you will understand that the sum of
these three figures makes up the 477
million of 178 million in the end but
that's not really intuitive at all how
this is shown especially given that for
instance this orange or this AWS yellow
orange type is more or less the same as
this yellow orange color here in the bar
charts right so you could assume that
maybe the bars here are actually AWS
which is I mean more or less exactly
what this Legend is applying but of
course this is not what's the case
because this here on the left is the
total where I see the three are
components of the total so if you look
at all the other slides more and more
problems like this are apparent I hope
you agree how these little things really
matter really add up to an impression of
such a document which is just incredibly
unprofessional I would of course be very
interested in your perspective as well
do you agree with this judgment do you
see it differently let me know what your
views in the comments very interested to
hear about that by the way if you want
to step up your slide writing game I'm
partnering with think cell the
PowerPoint plugin that is used for
almost all of the big consulting firms
to create charts I have a special offer
that I negotiated with things that are
for you with an extended free trial and
single licenses you can check it out in
the video description if you took any
value from this video at all hit the
like button for the YouTube algorithm
subscribe and turn on the notification
Bell my name is highlight releasing
weekly videos here on this channel see
you again next week all the best to you
and bye bye